boa tarde galera aqui disse lucena
aqui na minha cidade natal onde nasce aí
aonde que eu consegui a minha vida meu
pai minha mãe e eu saí do são paulo com
dois anos morei na rua com cinco anos de
idade
eu fiquei muito tempo sem trabalhar lá
são paulo a na rua papelão catar 40 e 50
na cabeça foi a única coisa que você não
tenha condições o radium na época era
era na época da vida pessoal de 15 anos
a jogar no lixo
foi onde eu achei ela
muito frio a lei é resgatar essa criança
é da onde eu sou de sons abusiva do
norte chegou aqui não eu cheguei aqui
através de pai e mãe eu sair daqui com
cinco anos meu pai 1989 eu fiquei
sozinho e hoje voltei pra casa porque
você tem condição de ficar esse tempo
todo na rua eu peguei e falei pra ele
assim eu saí de casa o que meu pai assim
é as coisas como se quantidade
o homem sair de casa ou trabalho e
roubar ninguém conseguir seu objetivo
a passagem de avião com o norte
a minha mulher com um show em caicó
fugir de novo e difícil sair de campinas
com o senhor que hoje com 11 anos a
trabalhar na área de ninguém
as costas e sair eu fui pa e campina
grande paraíba
foi onde eu comecei minha carreira de
jogador de futebol júnior semana o o meu
sonho não sabe ir ligando o norte
estatal
ele pegou e falou assim para mim eu vou
ter uma força possível e ficar aqui
consegui não consigo entender o momento
nada vou dar um conselho a 12 meses até
ser recuperar com você tá desatado no
meio nada
ele veio na minha mochila abril eu só
tinha só um pacote discutido as garrafas
de água que é o caminho
o trecho faz com que siga viagem no
mundo afora
foi daí 26 uma passagem
se aparecer a primeira foi a juazeiro da
bahia com o colina
cheguei retorno toda a europa
rg
na minha cidade que não tem o documento
gasolina onde trabalhava lá entrava e
funcional jogava nas horas vagas fazer
um bico no posto de gasolina com ele e
em 90 dias treinando lá aí esforço e
trabalho novo tá um lixo cada
o carro trabalhar
a carrocinha com um tempo de 1 45 vezes
até eu e um novo caminho e que a droga
fica muito exposto à vontade no dia 13
caminho a droga sua morte do menino guri
foi campeão e através da carroça 16
faixas meu sonho e fm e fm chegar o mês
com o projeto tratador foi o projeto
lado não foi na virada cultural estava
na carroça então inédito que o som
estava acabando utilizada no grafite vai
ver agora o que eu estava começando a
montar mas eu não tinha falado que não
tinha eu só tenho um sonho que eu tinha
comprado gastei 2.600 aqui eu não tinha
rádio 'antena de trabalho em quatro
meses em uma bateria para links na época
o rádio é um rádio e um sapato na copa
tal como na copa você tem idéia do que
estava fazendo nada de pessoal lista
cabelo tá fazendo massagem não quer
fazer mais aquilo que não faz uma saída
de uma academia boa academia valdéz que
isto não podia fazer
com quase 500 em criciúma um pouco pior
do mundo ainda fizeram ainda uma garrafa
não quero nominar o cenário a curva boa
aí aqui essa carroça que está o vento
foi na copa do mundo que estava montada
não estava completamente não tava cinco
centavos 60% montada
aí no primeiro dia começou a parecer um
alemão ele e mais três pessoas
toda rosa total e foi feito num
piquenique trata do conceito conseguiu
tal eu peguei e falei não é problema
porque semana a rússia não consegue as
coisas consegue só se você não usar
droga e não gastar com bebida você
consegue as coisas só se você quiser se
você não quiser você não consegue
aí a esse cara pegou e levou errou a
alemanha essa carroça pagou 15 mil reais
por dia 28 no finalzinho da copa jogou
15 mil em baleia ela e um grupo de
congonha alemã revelou contudo não quis
colocar lá embalou e levou avião de
carga e essa tia que estão vendo essa
aqui tem uma tv de 32 polegadas com
conversor digital já nessa aí liga dos
campeões e tva ea liga dos campeões que
eu assisti no meio da rua e eu não tinha
sky ainda tem idéia
aí eu gastei 24 mil reais para deixar o
retrato aí essa aqui apanhar sem gols tv
de led assinatura da sky gerador a
gasolina e aqui eu colocar uma pessoa
para assistir os jogos aí assim final do
campeonato feminino o brasil perdeu a
classificação para a final
eu tenho criança e idosos utentes a melô
morador de rua o usuário de crack e tudo
e tudo em volta a assistir no e se vocês
quiserem ler você não perder e essa aqui
é o seguinte essa aqui foi onde foi
finalizada foi aqui no largo da batata
no dia 23 de dezembro ouvindo do centro
da cidade pra cá eu falei eu tenho que
ligar o momento a maioria vai fazer um
grafite um dia que eu cheguei aqui
estava muito ver não tá muito forte a
chuva a chuva dar uma trégua e furtava e
roubava colocada uma tenda não descobriu
a causa com o aluno e na visão da fitch
mesmo debaixo de chuva um aluno em tudo
está do lado da escada estava sentindo a
idéia surgiu quando a china sportv
não não está fazendo graf aí
e aqui é essa coleta coface cocato
dentro um ano contra são bernardo e
colocou carrego o mês
e aqui eu estava na estação da luz onde
eu não fiz essa foto não diga que ele
poderia fazer a entrevista total ele
queria então a galera vai fazer como no
dia não tinha como não tinha muita gente
eu falei com o pessoal não é como tem
paciência de ficar ficar no lugar das
drogas não têm como fica aí eu contei um
futebol algum clima com a novela hoje o
pessoal se junta ao redor do carro em
paciente mesmo com o pouco contato que
eu chamo de senão que a fissura é tão
grande
por lei eles fumavam natal fazia tudo
então eu chamo atenção desde o pessoal
hoje a droga hoje não são tudo hoje às
drogas no momento hoje não existe tudo a
droga bebida posição não é tudo é tudo
hoje tudo hoje você compra de jogo você
tem que curtir sua vida que você chega à
sua idade começa a ficar velho que
acontece você na sua vida você não fez
nada não fez nada completamente que
acabou toda sua vida no mais droga na
medição das drogas que acontece aí eu
peguei e falei pra eles sentem no chão
conhecendo ficou eu ele ea mulher dele e
os dois filhos são os aplicar essa
riqueza que você esteve vocês têm a
coragem de pegar trocar por droga
ele falou pra mim eu já fiz as duas vez
duas vezes seguinte ele pega as crianças
no dia seguinte tentou devolve o que
devolve porque quando ele era criança
dele parece que o mundo dele acabou
acabou tudo por hoje a riqueza que nós
tenhamos nossos filhos não apenas o
filho não tem nada hoje
então é a vida que nós leva no dia a dia
na rua
o concerto é o que está puxando a
carroça também não sabia catando latinha
você está a mexer nada a ninguém
tá você tá limpo na cidade de taez
poluindo o ambiente
você está tirando o próximo da rua então
eu fiz de tudo essa montagem com o som
da banda com pessoal que na rua você
consegue ter seu dia a dia seu
dinheirinho na sua cozinha
tudo através do lixo então eu bandido
através do lixo dos outros com um leve
sorriso usar eletrônico para você usar o
eleitor com é lixo mas pra mim o
trabalho não é uma peça daquela consigo
fazer outra uma tv que vai do tiro um
compostor e põe na outra conseguiu
funcionar através desse aparelho
eletrônico esse lixo
uma vez eu estava na água quando eu
peguei peguei três moleque com nove de
dez a 12 anos
tire um dia você coleta comigo aí nesse
dia eu já estava chegando já chegou
fazendo uma palestra e ele chegou nada
chegou a mulher estava do meu lado
perguntou o que você não tem um f não
tem uma renda porque não tem fim
estou lutando na vida eu consigo me foi
móvel a as crianças que está no meio das
drogas a idéia droga fica no meio de nós
mesmos que eu falo no meio da mídia fala
pra eles que fiquem na rua você é
obrigado a viver a vida pessoal pensa
que tudo vocês querem se envolver nas
drogas
então hoje as drogas não são tudo eu
tenho essa causa pavor de mostrar o
pessoal que vocês podem investir nelas
uma carroça moradia numa casa em
funcionamente completamente é um é um
cenário sem multa
o futebol mesmo quem não gosta de
futebol vocês todos vocês gostam não tem
dono a copa do mundo mesmo todo mundo
estava nos dedos
então se eu colocar uma carroça na rua
com a sky ou qualquer operadora com a
rua e é um sinal e cozinhar
ele é perfeito para o que é perfeito
para outro já não é
ele fala que é o ganges o que é passar
um dia você tem escala eu não tenho não
você pode ter sobre o compromisso que
separa no final no meio da sua
cervejinha se eu tirasse 10 real chega
por semana você veja você pode ter uma
assinatura é barata
você compõe antena 1 antena não é caro
segundo zezé como antenas e pode ser o
futebol com a sua família e seus amigos
os seus filhos com todo o conteúdo
pessoal
então eu quero mostrar um pouco em todos
nós tem também a condição eu ou seja
qualquer um tem condição
eu vou encerrar essa palestra através de
vocês obrigada